على امل اقناع الجمهوريين بمواصله تقديم
المساعدات لبلاده بقيمه 61 مليار دولار
الرئيس الاوكراني فولوديمير زيلنسكي حذر
واشنطن من ان ايقاف المساعدات الامريكيه
امر سيحقق احلام الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين الاوكرانيين لم يستسلموا ولن يستسلم
نعلم جيدا ما يجب علينا القيام به يمكنكم
الاعتماد على اوكرانيا ونامل ان نتمكن من
الاعتماد عليكم بنفس
القدر من المقرر ان يلتقي زيلنسكي اليوم
بالرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن وشخصيات بارزه
من الكونغرس من الحزبين الديمقراطي
والجمهوري بمن فيهم رئيس مجلس النواب
الجمهوري مايك جونسون على مدى فتره الحرب
مع روسيا اعتمدت القوات الاوكرانيه بشده
على دعم غربي بقياده الولايات المتحده شمل
تسليمها خائره واسلحه ومساعدات اخرى اخرى
عسكريه وماليه تقدر بعشرات مليارات
الدولارات عرقل الاعضاء الجمهوريون في
مجلس الشيوخ الامريكي الاسبوع الماضي طلب
البيت الابيض اقرار حزمه طارئه بقيمه 106
مليارات دولار كمساعدات لاوكرانيا
واسرائيل
خصوصا هذا وقت حاسم وهذا هو الوقت المناسب
تماما لاحضار رئيس زيلينسكي لاجراء هذه
المناقشات بسبب ما يحدث في اوكرانيا
والنشاط المتزايد للقوات المسلحه الروسيه
مع اقتراب فصل الشتاء وما يحدث في
الكابيتل تاتي هذه الزياره في سياق قمه
اوروبيه من المرتقب عقدها هذا الاسبوع
وسيتعين على الدول ال7 ان تقرر ما اذا
كانت ستواصل دعمها العسكري والمالي
لاوكرانيا